[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen im Sport
gleicht der Blick auf die Fußball-WM von
Rudi Cerne hallo schönen guten Abend in
Niger spitz sich die Sicherheitslage zu
raus aus Niger nach dem Putsch in dem
afrikanischen Land fliegt das
französische Militär hunderte Europäer
aus auch deutsche können mit
zubis verzweifelt gesucht vor einem
Handwerk fehlt der Nachwuchs und die
Geburten schwachen Jahrgänge kommen erst
noch
so viel Matsch war seltene beim
Metal-Festival in Wagen ist das Gelände
so durch weich dass jetzt ein
anreise-stopp für Besucher mit Autos
gilt
[Musik]
durch die Militärputsch in Niger wächst
die Sorge dass die gesamte
westafrikanische Region weiter die
stabilisiert werden könnte das
Auswärtige Amt hat jetzt eine
Reisewarnung ausgesprochen und allen
deutschen geraten den nieder zu
verlassen frankreich will heute mit
evakuierungsflügen beginnen über die
Lage in niedersandra Theiss
dicht gedrängt stehen Sie am Flughafen
wollen Niger verlassen Frankreich fliegt
seine und andere EU-Bürger aus dem Land
aus die erste Maschine sollte noch heute
starten viel Zeit zu packen hatten die
Menschen nicht
uns wurde gesagt packt nur das nötigste
in eine kleine Tasche für einen Koffer
ist kein Platz
ein Krisenstab in Paris organisiert die
Evakuierungen Frankreich bietet an auch
deutsche mitzunehmen
wir schätzen dass es hunderte Franzosen
sind die das Land verlassen wollen
hinzukommen ein paar hundert Europäer
und sie wissen ja es ist Tradition
zwischen europäischen Ländern
Solidarität zu zeigen
vor zwei Tagen hatten Demonstranten die
die neuen Machthaber unterstützen die
französische Botschaft in der Hauptstadt
niami angegriffen Niger war einst
französische Kolonie eine solche Gefahr
für die Deutschen vor Ort sieht das
Auswärtige Amt derzeit nicht rät aber
dazu das französische Angebot anzunehmen
auch die westafrikanische
Staatengemeinschaft ecovas hat reagiert
in einer Krisensitzung stellte sie den
Putschisten ein Ultimatum droht mit
Gewalt sollte der abgesetzte Präsident
bei Zoom bis Sonntag wieder im Amt sein
die beiden Nachbarländer von Niger
Marley und Burkina Faso wo bereits
Militärregierungen herrschen reagierten
prompt und stellten sich hinter die
putschenden Militärs in Niger beide
erklärten wortgleich
jegliche militärische Intervention wird
als Kriegserklärung gegen Burkina Faso
und Mali betrachtet
der Putsch in Niger betrifft auch den
Abzug der rund 1.000 deutschen Soldaten
aus Mali der sollte über den
lufttransportstützpunkt in niamelaufen
wo weitere 100 Bundeswehrsoldaten
stationiert sind dort soll auch ein
Transportflugzeug bereitstehen um im
Notfall deutsche aus Niger rauszubringen
vor welcher jahrlogistischen
Herausforderung steht die
Bundesregierung jetzt in Niger also sie
steht gleich vor einer doppelten
Herausforderung das eine ist die
Sicherheit der Deutschen die sich
aktuell in Liga aufhalten inklusive der
dort ja stationierten Bundeswehrsoldaten
und die zweite Herausforderung ist das
der Abzug der deutschen Truppen aus dem
benachbarten Mali über den großen
Flughafen hier mehr in Niger erfolgen
sollte weil die dafür unter anderem
eingesetzten Iljuschin Frachtflugzeuge
einmal zwischen tanken müssen da sie vom
Bundeswehrstandort in Mali nicht voll
bedankt abheben können dieses Drehkreuz
ist jetzt erstmal zum Stillstand
gekommen und es gibt heute Meldungen
dass die Bundeswehr schon Ausweichrouten
unter anderem über Algerien benutzt das
Verteidigungsministerium wollte aber
eben nur bestätigen dass man alternative
Flugrouten prüfe
warten wir mal weiter den Blick auf die
Region was hat in der Putsche Liga für
politische Folgen also aus Sicht der
Bundesregierung viel größerer als wenn
das auf den ersten Blick denken würde
denn Niger galt für den Westen als
Letzter stabiler Anker in der ganzen
Sahelzone wo ja mittlerweile an vielen
Stellen Terrorgruppen die Kontrolle
übernommen haben sei es al-Qaida oder
Boko Haram und bisher hat die Regierung
in Niger die Migration Richtung Europa
begrenzt wenn das künftig wegfällt dann
könnten Schlepper wieder wie das ja
schon vor Jahren so war tausende
Flüchtlinge durch die Wüste nach Libyen
bringen und von dort auf Boote nach
Italien und übrigens für Frankreichs und
Europas Atomkraftwerke ist nieder ein
extrem wichtiger Uran Lieferant auch das
könnte Auswirkungen haben also Niger ist
in mancher Hinsicht viel wichtiger und
näher als man das vermuten würde danke
für diese Einordnung in Berlin
zu den möglichen Evakuierungen gleich
ein ZDF heute live aus nia mai
zugeschaltet der Chef der
Hilfsorganisation gegen den Hunger in
Niger um 19:30 Uhr in unserer ZDF heute
App und auf unseren Social Media Kanälen
zum deutschen Arbeitsmarkt da
hinterlässt die schwächelnde Konjunktur
ihre Spuren die Zahl der Arbeitslosen
ist weiter gestiegen insgesamt halte
sich der Arbeitsmarkt aber gut so die
zuständige Bundesagentur demnach waren
im Juli
2,617 Millionen Menschen ohne Job das
sind 62.000 mehr als im Juni die Quote
erhöht sich leicht auf 5,7 Prozent im
Vergleich zum Vorjahr waren es 147.000
Arbeitslose mehr
1 August für viele Azubis hat heute das
Ausbildungsjahr begonnen 10.000
Lehrstellen bleiben allerdings auch
dieses Mal unbesetzt wie auch schon in
den Jahren zuvor aktuell sind bundesweit
rund
228.000 Ausbildungsstellen offen ein
Trend der zahlreichen Betrieben große
Nachwuchs sorgen bereitet besonders
betroffen sind etwa Branchen wie der
Handel oder das Handwerk Bäckereien zum
Beispiel hier versucht man jetzt Azubis
mit mehr Geld zu locken Claudia Oberst
berichtet
hier in Saarwellingen im Saarland
entstehen gerade Hefezöpfe knapp 30
Bäcker und Konditorinnen arbeiten hier
drei Azubis starten im neuen
Ausbildungsjahr die Chefin er rekrutiert
ihren Nachwuchs über Praktika wirbt
offensiv
wir haben dieses Jahr auch tatsächlich
Auszubildende gefunden wir gehen in die
Schule wir müssen wir müssen nach
draußen wir dürfen uns als Handwerk
nicht verstecken aktuell gibt es rund
1500 offene Lehrstellen im
Bäckerhandwerk der neue Tarifvertrag
soll Abhilfe schaffen
der Vertrag beinhaltet pro Monat 180 bis
200 Euro mehr Gehalt heißt im ersten
Lehrjahr 860 € brutto 50 €
Inflationsausgleich und 29 Euro
Fahrtkostenzuschuss
der Tarifvertrag ist wichtig für die
Branche weil unser Bäckerhandwerk damit
ein Quantensprung macht im Bereich der
Ausbildungsvergütung und wir setzen
damit einen deutliches Signal in
Richtung der jungen Menschen in Richtung
der Auszubildenden ihr seid uns wichtig
Christian Seidler ist gerade fertig mit
der Ausbildung er musste noch mit
weniger Geld zurechtkommen
Bedingungen mehr junge für das Handwerk
begeistern damit Ihr Betrieb und eine
der ältesten deutschen Traditionen eine
Zukunft hat
und noch eine wichtige Zahl mit fast 88
Prozent sind Deutschlands Gasspeicher
aktuell gut gefüllt
und das trotz der ausbleibenden
Lieferungen aus Russland der gasstopp
nach Beginn des ukrainekrieges im
vergangenen Jahr hatte vor allem das
Energieunternehmen Juniper getroffen
Deutschlands bis dahin größter
gasimporteur ging deshalb fast pleite
und wurde nach Milliarden Verlusten
verstaatlicht jetzt geht es wieder
deutlich bergauf in Arbeit
Juniper ist vorerst auferstanden
innerhalb von acht Monaten denn netto
gewinnen im ersten Halbjahr fast 2,5
Milliarden Euro
und ab 8 Monaten würden wir durch den
deutschen Staat finanziell stabilisiert
und haben bereits kurz danach den
Turnaround geschafft
die massive Talfahrt des Aktienkurses in
2022 ist gestoppt heute nähert sich die
Aktie der 6 € Marke 99% der Anteile
gehören jetzt im Bund hier im
Handelsraum bei Juniper machten sie
vergangenes Jahr durch fehlendes Gas aus
Russland und die teure Ersatzbeschaffung
Millionenverluste täglich der Staat
musste einsteigen die
Versorgungssicherheit des Landes war in
Gefahr
der Einstieg des Staates bei uniper war
alternativlos wir hatten damals ein sehr
kritische Situationen und wäre der Staat
nicht eingestiegen werde gesamte
erdgasmakt und auch die gesamte
Energiewirtschaft zusammengebrochen und
dann auch die deutsche Wirtschaft im
Moment steht Juniper Blenden da ein
Vorteil auch für die Verbraucher denn
die Gaspreise sind überraschend niedrig
der Winter war mild die Speicher sind
voll Deutschland hat LNG also
verflüssigtes Gas angekauft und neue
Importeure gefunden über die Rückzahlung
der Staatshilfen ist der Vorstand nun
mit der Bundesregierung im Gespräch
zudem soll der Gewinn genutzt werden um
den Konzern CO2 freizumachen bis 2014 10
Jahre früher als geplant
über die Förderung neuer Wasserstoff und
Gaskraftwerke in Deutschland sind sich
EU-Kommission im Bundesregierung im
Grundsatz einig das sagt
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck er spricht
von einem politischen Durchbruch auf dem
Weg zu einer CO2-freien
Energieversorgung geplant seien
staatliche Zuschüsse für steuerbare
Kraftwerke sie soll sogenannte
dunkelflauten abdecken Zeiten in denen
kein Wind weht und die Sonne nicht
scheint
der russische Angriff auf die Ukraine
hat den Umsatz der deutschen
Rüstungsindustrie nach oben schnellen
lassen zu einem Teil soll künftig auch
das Kampfflugzeug F35 in Deutschland
gefertigt werden dafür baut rein Metall
jetzt eine neue Fabrik in
Nordrhein-Westfalen
2025 soll sie im Betrieb genommen werden
über den heutigen Baubeginn der Fabrik
berichtet Peter Böhmer
es war ein ganz breiter Spatenstich am
Flughafen Weeze nahe der holländischen
Grenze Rüstungsindustrie
militärs-präsident wüst Rüstung ist
plötzlich angesagt lange Jahre war das
nicht der Fall auch seitens der Politik
ja ärgern kann einen so etwas aber ich
war ich bin seit 25 Jahren oder 30
Jahren überzeugt davon dass es richtig
ist was wir machen für Demokratie und
für die für den Frieden und auch
letztendlich für die Freiheit unseres
Landes zu kämpfen lass uns nicht
zurückschauen lassen nach vorne schauen
ist gut dass jetzt Tempo drauf kommt
dass wir unsere Verteidigungsfähigkeit
stärken und deswegen ist das eine gute
Entscheidung hier in Nordrhein-Westfalen
diese Fabrik zu bauen in Weeze sollen
Teile gefertigt werden für den Rumpf der
amerikanischen F35 eines Tarnkappen
Bombers der auch den Tornado der
Bundeswehr ablösen soll 400
Arbeitsplätze sollen direkt in der
Fabrik entstehen weitere 1.500 könnten
es bei Zulieferern sein
für Experten läuft der Ausbau der
Verteidigungsindustrie aber zu langsam
generell ist es so dass unsere
Produktionskapazitäten viel zu niedrig
sind also wenn wir die Bundeswehr
ausstatten wollen so dass sie nicht erst
im Jahr 2040 sondern schnell
einsatzbereit wird wenn wir gleichzeitig
die Ukraine unterstützen wollen unsere
Verpflichtungen in der NATO erfüllen
wollen dann brauchen wir viel höhere
Produktionskapazitäten das zum Beispiel
die Munition in zwei Jahren produziert
werden kann und nicht in 20 Jahren
immerhin in Weeze sagt Rheinmetall waren
es zwischen ersten Gesprächen bis zum
heutigen Spatenstich nur sechs Monate
der Ukraine Krieg sorgt für ungewohntes
Tempo bei der Realisierung von
Industrieprojekten
der ukrainische Botschafter in Berlin
macaref drängt Deutschland zu weiteren
Waffenlieferungen konkret spricht davon
Marschflugkörpern und Langstrecken
Raketen dabei gehen die Kämpfe zwischen
Russland und der Ukraine weiter in
Hassan sollen die Besatzer ein
Krankenhaus beschossen haben ein Arzt
sei dabei ums Leben gekommen so die
Behörden
wurde ein Wohngebäude fast vollständig
zerstört
auch Russland meldet neue
Drohnenangriffe wieder sein Moskau das
Ziel gewesen und wieder habe es ein
Hochhaus im Finanzviertel getroffen
die Parteien im Bundestag bekommen
wieder mehr Großspenden insgesamt
994.44 Euro waren es im ersten Halbjahr
2023 so die Bundestagsverwaltung das war
mehr als doppelt so viel wie im
Vorjahreszeitraum
Großspenden sind Zuwendungen ab 50.000
Euro die bislang größte Einzelspende in
diesem Jahr über
265.000 Euro ging an die AFD
CSU und Linke gingen leer aus
der Brand auf dem Auto fragt da vor der
niederländischen Küste soll Konsequenzen
haben die Welt schifffahrtsorganisation
will die Sicherheitsvorkehrungen für den
Transport von E-Autos verschärfen und
sagt das stehe ganz oben auf der
Tagesordnung knapp eine Woche nach
Ausbruch des Feuers cotton
bergungsspezialisten das Wrack an seinem
neuen Liegeplatz erkunden das Feuer sei
zwar erloschen Grund zur Entwarnung sei
das aber noch nicht nun soll das Schiff
nach Möglichkeit in einen Hafen
geschleppt werden
wir kommen nach miamar vor zweieinhalb
Jahren wurde dort die
Friedensnobelpreisträgerin aus
hanssoucci festgenommen nun hat die
Militär runter angekündigt ihre
Haftstrafe etwas zu reduzieren
im Februar 2021 hatte das Militär
gepusht und die demokratisch gewählte de
facto-regierungschefin abgesetzt sie
wurde unter anderem wegen Korruption
verurteilt die ursprünglichen 33 Jahre
Haft wurden jetzt auf 27 verkürzt
aus einigen Gebieten Chinas werden
derzeit die schwersten Überschwemmungen
seit 50 Jahren gemeldet mehr als eine
halbe Million Menschen sind vom
Tropensturm durch Suri betroffen vor
allem in und um die Hauptstadt Peking
über die dramatischen Versuche Menschen
aus den Fluten zu retten berichtet
unsere Korrespondentin Miriam Steiner
neben den Schreckensnachrichten aus Nord
China gibt es in diesen Tagen auch
Helden wie diesen Busfahrer der einen
alten Mann entdeckt
mit vereinten Kräften ziehen Sie ihn aus
dem Wasser
[Applaus]
auch dieser Mann hat Glück er überlebt
den Überschlag seines gefluteten Autos
und kann kurze Zeit später gerettet
werden
andere schaffen das nicht
da sind die Lichter noch an noch
Menschen drin
offiziell meldet Peking 11 Tote und 27
vermisste wie viele es wirklich sind
weiß niemand
innerhalb weniger Stunden fällt so viele
Regen wie normalerweise während des
ganzen Monats den besten und die
westlichen Vororte Pekings trifft es
besonders hart
auch das staatlich kontrollierte
Fernsehen berichtet in erster Linie über
Rettungsmaßnahmen
hunderte Flüge waren verspätet oder
wurden gecancelt im Osten von Peking hat
sich die Lage zum Abend hin beruhigt
wie hier hatte die Stadt vor dem Sturm
aus vielen Flüssen und sehen das Wasser
abgelassen und zu verhindern dass sie
Überlaufen der Regen in den vergangenen
Tagen war so stark dass der Fluss schon
wieder komplett voll ist
im Südwesten der Stadt Posten Menschen
Videos mit ihrem Standort und ihrer
Handynummer und bitten um Hilfe
die Heavy Metal Fans dorthin fürs
legendäre Festival dieses Mal jedoch
kommt nicht mal die Polizei durch Stau
und Dauerregen die Stimmung bei den
meisten trotzdem ausgelassen die Heike
große berechnet
wer Heavy Metal Fan ist liebt Matsch und
davon gibt es in Wacken in diesem Jahr
genug vielleicht sogar ein bisschen zu
viel denn wegen dauerregenz sind die
campingwiesen gesperrt
viele anreisende Besucher stehen seit
gestern im endlosstaub die ganz Harten
Heavy Metal Fans lassen sich nicht
aufhalten und gehen zu Fuß
für die meisten ging es aber auch heute
noch nicht voran trotz der Regenpausen
wir haben diese Insel jetzt hier zu
unserem Eigentum erklärt letzter Arsch
der Heide 23
und ich glaube wir bleiben hier
es gibt kein schlechtes Wetter es gibt
eine schlechte Getränke und die haben
wir nicht
knapp 20 Kilometer vor Wacken fanden die
strandete Asyl auf dem Parkplatz eines
Baumarkts einige davon im
mustergartenhaus Modell Isa wir bekommen
hier gleich Strom rein die hat Dixi Klos
bestellt damit wir also hier die Zeit
überbrücken können das macht also echt
viel Spaß jetzt hier zu sein wir
versuchen das Beste draus zu machen die
Veranstalter fordern alle auf nicht
weiter nach Wacken zu kommen den Fans
die schon da sind ist das egal
viele gute Laune ja Mädel Mädel Metal
Leute noch ist das Festival nicht
abgesagt aber der Dauerregen soll
zurückkommen nach Wacken das heißt noch
mehr Matsch doch echte Fans kann der
nicht stoppen
bei der Fußball-WM der Frauen sind heute
ja die nächsten Teams die Corona
eingezogen manche dabei sehr souverän
die Fußballspielerinnen der Niederlande
sind zum Beispiel locker ins
Achtelfinale der WM in Australien und
Neuseeland eingezogen gegen WM-Neuling
Vietnam gelangen ein überzeugender 7 zu
0 Sieg Titelverteidiger USA stammte
hingegen haarscharf am Vorrunden aus
vorbei am Ende reichte aber das 0:0
gegen Portugal um weiterzukommen
es war dieser pfostenschutz in der
Nachspielzeit von Anna karpeter der den
Puls auf beiden Seiten noch mal gehörig
in die Höhe trieb es hätte der
Siegtreffer für Portugal sein können der
für die Titelverteidigerinnen aus den
USA den Ko in diesem WM-Turnier bedeutet
hätte und das aus wäre nicht unverdient
gewesen nach einem Spiel der
Weltmeisterinnen bei dem häufig die
Präzision fehlte auch die Einwechslung
von Superstar Megan repino brachte keine
entscheidenden Impulse nur Zentimeter
fehlen Portugal zur Sensation
stattdessen nun die Heimreise die USA
zittern sich glanzlos als Gruppen zweite
ins Achtelfinale
den Gruppensieg holt sich im
Parallelspiel souverän die Niederlande
das oranier-team gegen Vietnam mit dem
höchsten Sieg seiner WM Geschichte ein
Treffer schöner als der andere am Ende
steht es sieben zu null
und mit einer makellosen Bilanz sind
englands-spielerinnen in die Runde der
letzten 16 eingezogen die lyonesses
gewannen in Adelaide auch ihr drittes
Gruppenspiel gegen China mit 6:1 Rachel
daily erzielte den Siegtreffer für die
Europameisterinnen die damit auch ihre
Ambitionen auf den WM Titel
unterstreichen konnten eben
Parallelspiel der Gruppe D hat Dänemark
gegen Haiti mit 2:0 gewonnen Sonne
trulcard macht den Sieg in der
Nachspielzeit perfekt Dänemark damit als
Gruppen zweiter nach 16-jähriger WM
Abstinenz ebenfalls im Achtelfinale
alle Tore und Zusammenfassungen aller
Spiele dieser WM finden Sie übrigens
online bei uns in der ZDF Mediathek oder
unter sportstudio.de und für das
deutsche Team wird es Donnerstag Mittag
wieder ernst in Brisbane steht das
Gruppenfinale gegen Südkorea auf dem
Programm live bei uns im ZDF um einen
Ausscheiden ganz sicher zu verhindern
muss an sie her
da ist Spaß und auch ein bisschen
Pfeffer drin sie sind gut drauf im
Training wichtig vor dem entscheidenden
Gruppenspiel wir erwarten mit
südkoreaden taktisch gut eingestellten
Gegner die wirklich auch sehr disponiert
verteidigen werden sehr wahrscheinlich
wieder fit Marina Hegering die
Abwehrchefin wird nach dem Ausfall von
Sarah Dorsten dringend gebraucht das WM
aus soll verhindert werden Marina
Hegering wenn sie denn wirklich zu 100%
fit ist kann jeder Mannschaft helfen sie
lässt sich auch von dieser
Drucksituation überhaupt nicht irgendwie
beeinflussen auch die kopfverstärke
Angreiferin leer Schüler steht wohl in
der Startelf nach der schwachen
Offensivleistung gegen Kolumbien muss
ein Sieg her der nur dann hat
Deutschland das Weiterkommen selbst in
der Hand
wir sind gespannt und das war's
und jetzt noch das Hopfen und Malz sind
nicht ganz verloren
alkoholfreies Bier wird bei den
Deutschen immer beliebter die Produktion
hat sich innerhalb von zehn Jahren fast
verdoppelt so die wie immer nüchternen
Zahlen des Statistischen Bundesamtes
allerdings ging der Absatz von wir mit
Alkohol in der gleichen Zeit um gut
zwölf Prozent zurück der deutsche
brauer-
Kühe regnerisch windig die Aussichten
muten eher früh herbstlich als
hochsommerlich an mehr gleich von Katja
horneffer das heute journal läuft um
21:45 Uhr mit Christian Sievers schönen
Abend noch
[Musik]
guten Abend in lockerer Folge brausen
die Tiefs über uns hinweg sie bringen
Regenschauer mit Gewitter zwischendurch
zeigt sich dann aber auch mal die Sonne
und diese Thies dämpfen die Temperaturen
die lagen so heute Nachmittag in West
und Nordeuropa bei 14 bis 22 Grad Malaga
meldete dagegen in Spanien 40 Grad heute
Nacht sinken die Werte bei uns am
Alpenrand auf 10 Grad 16 Grad sind es am
Oberrhein der Regen lässt jetzt erstmal
nach aber in der zweiten Nachthälfte
setzt er dann von Westen wieder ein und
dann werden sich diese Regenwolken
morgen weiter Richtung Osten ausbreiten
am längsten Freund ist es morgen
Vormittag hier noch im Nordosten und
auch am Alpenrand werden sie wohl den
ganzen Tag über die Sonne sehen kann am
Nachmittag entwickelt sich im Westen
kräftige Schauer und Gewitter in
Nordrhein-Westfalen in Rheinland-Pfalz
und auch in Hessen dann nimmt auch der
Wind stürmisch zu die Temperaturen
liegen morgen bei 19 Grad in den
Mittelgebirgen und auch in
Schleswig-Holstein und maximal 26
am alpenrad in den nächsten Tagen geht
es wechselhaft weiter mit Regenschauern
und Gewittern und bei Temperaturen von
16 bis 24 Grad guten Abend